bom dia a todos
obrigado pra ela presença num sábado de
manhã
sabe como é fácil obrigado ano pelo
convite
apresento aqui é só a gente entende
aquilo que já ouviu falar e pelo pe
a segurança ficará o resto da sala
também falta de cabelo à la ao mercado a
sua rede brasil é pelo transportation
tecnológica uma empresa dele usada por
ela manske e eu faço parte de uma
geração é é x entre y e x que nunca se
enquadrou e nenhum é o status quo de
trabalho que a gente tem aqui no brasil
nem sempre foi muito muito questionado
muito desafiador de tudo que eu via pela
frente é sempre desde muito cedo a gente
eu tinha a mania de querer entender como
funcionam as coisas num país que a gente
é ensinado a não entender nada a gente a
gente cresce aprendendo aqui aquele é o
jeito certo vamos fazer daquele jeito
não tem nada o que mudar
eu nunca nunca me encaixei em nenhum
desses formatos de trabalho isso me fez
alguns me trouxe algumas divergências
durante a vida e que um mês meus
trabalhos meus projetos
as empresas que vão abrir às empresas
que eu quebrei enfim então é em algum
momento da vida
me sentia necessidade de correr atrás do
que efetivamente eu queria então eu sou
mineiro de belo horizonte eu saí de
minas já tem muitos anos mas hoje estou
em são paulo
bom de vez em quando eu tenho são paulo
mas eh eh e aí a gente começa a entender
o que é a vida que eu trabalho entender
um pouco o que é esse mundo esse mundo
de inovação nesse momento comecei a
entender o que quer esse mundo de
inovação eu já estava já tinha uma
carreira executiva já tem mais ou menos
15 anos quando eu comecei isso e em
algum momento eu acabei esquecendo de
quem era e me tornando essa pessoa é
tinha 111 tinha um bom salário não
estava na minha zona de conforto é
cargos executivos em são paulo muito bem
mas não era e não era feliz né gente
em fases na vida que a gente se acostuma
e depois a gente percebe que a gente não
tá feliz nesse momento eu comecei a ter
problemas no trabalho obviamente né não
conseguia entender o motivo daquela
naquele aqueles problemas e eu me dei
conta me lembrei de tudo aquilo que já
tinha estudado gente já tinha vivido e
lembrei de que efetivamente aquilo era
pra mim e aí eu comecei a fazer uma uma
análise de tudo o que eu já tinha feito
na vida e onde estava naquele momento um
carro interessante tinha uma uma
segurança interessante mas toda a minha
experiência estava sendo jogada fora
porque eu me acomodei eu estava naquele
momento deixando de fazer o que eu
gostaria deixando de construir alguma
coisa pra de melhor para esse mundo que
foi quando de repente isso aconteceu na
minha vida
é ela a mãe que é o idealizador da da
tecnologia é piloto e nem acho que quem
conhece aqui sabe a história que já leu
o livro de eli sabiá história
então nesse momento quando eu recebi
esse convite as coisas começaram a mudar
então hoje
hoje eu sou o mentor o empreendedor o
investidor o networking o spink1
futurista e um conselheiro de startups a
gente faz esse trabalho no brasil afora
tudo isso aconteceu porque eu conseguia
efetivamente sair da minha da minha
rotina de de segurança e efetivamente
sair do mercado e tentar entender né
então hoje o que estou fazendo hoje
estou mudando o mundo tentando
efetivamente trazer uma qualidade de
vida melhor uma uma estabilidade melhor
para todos nós que estamos aqui e como é
que eu estou fazendo isso é como é que a
gente está fazendo isso
inovação porque simplesmente não é pelo
piúma uma tecnologia que até cinco anos
atrás 56 anos atrás
existia e hoje a gente está efetivamente
construindo mas no final vocês vão ver
um vizinho que mostra um pouco dessa
construção
nem o que é a a mobilizar o que a ré
pelo agente diga no mundo hoje que tem
uma crise gigantesca de mobilidade né
não só aqui no brasil não só aqui em são
paulo mas no mundo todo o que a gente o
que a gente vê hoje no mundo acontecendo
é basicamente isso é isso é isso é isso
a china então não é um problema
brasileiro não é um problema américa
latina não é um problema dos países em
desenvolvimento é um país em londres
é um problema que acontece efetivamente
no mundo inteiro os modais de transporte
que a gente tem hoje não são escaláveis
né não é possível se construir metrô
trem estrada e hidrovia de forma
escalável elas têm o seu limite
a gente precisa efetivamente de uma
solução que seja mais inteligente mais
eficientes sustentáveis e japão a gente
resolver um problema deles lá assim na
mentira não é verdade chamado white gluz
esses caras que ficam empurrando as
pessoas e aí banestes ao ápice da crise
nem o avanço do problema de mobilidade
do mundo
um dos países mais mais populoso do
planeta e o que é um é pelo nep núcleo é
basicamente isso aí né isso é pelo time
ainda não está bem rapidinho pra você se
lembra dos edson nã o chefe da manhã ele
ele sai correndo
isso é piloto não é não é brincadeira
mas é basicamente isso não é piloto não
é isso
isso o rapper luta é só uma cápsula
a gente já tem uma pronta já tem mais
cinco em produção
o mundo está no nosso site é pelo ponto
globo só estar disponível os nossos
vídeos nossas imagens ela é uma cápsula
que se desloque se locomove dentro de um
tubo a vaca o tubo é tem quatro metros
de diâmetro tem 17 de bombas no pé de
cada de cada um manda a cada dez
quilômetros que retiro aquele tubo e faz
com que essa cápsula se locomova até
1.200 quilômetros por hora
fazendo isso por uma realidade brasil a
gente está falando aqui ele de são paulo
desculpa que a gente está falando aqui
em são paulo campinas em seis minutos
isso é o que a gente está falando aqui é
importante que eu dizer que a gente o
que estou falando aqui não é para 30 40
50 anos
isso é real hoje a gente está
construindo e vocês vão ver isso
qual o impacto disso nessa luta um
sistema completamente insustentável não
utilize é como se fosse
é um sistema muito mais eficiente é o
custo
custa muito menos do que o metrô a
equipe do euro hoje
então é um sistema que efetivamente traz
uma série de benefícios para todos nós
ninguém que vai precisar escolher
namorada mas por onde ela mora
a gente vai poder morar longe e mesmo
assim tenho namorada então a gente está
falando que a gente vai ter um impacto
real na na especulação imobiliária na
geração de energia no transporte de
passageiro enfim tudo isso efetivamente
mudando transformar o mundo veja abaixo
a música federal muita cabeça para baixo
hoje as cidades são construídos em volta
das estradas das rodovias etc
ele está fazendo o contrário está
criando um modal em cima do dado ser
humano né pela empresa completamente
focada no ser humano a necessidade que
você tem de no final de semana
jantar com almoçar com a família
diferença nesse cenário que você tem que
se deslocar para trabalhar ou para uma
reunião ou para fazer uma viagem com
isso tudo está sendo pensado de forma
com que a gente possa efetivamente
trazer um benefício muito maior para o
ser humano
motivação não sempre não se prendam aos
aos paradigmas já está a construir 11
uma uma infraestrutura do zero é pelo
não existia
se a gente fosse ouvir sobre se a gente
parasse com qualquer desafio qualquer
obstáculo a gente tivesse a gente já
teria desistido lembre se que a gente
está construindo em cinco anos 56 uma um
modal de transporte que não existia até
então né
é vamos errar a empresa que era
constantemente o erro é supervalorizado
vamos raiva rápido para que a gente
consegue isso o rumo e se adapte certa e
vamos adaptar
neco joão estava falando exatamente isso
velocidade para adaptação a gente vive
num mundo que não cabe mais modelos
engessados então as coisas mudam as
coisas coisas se adaptam a gente precisa
estar a par disso a gente precisa estar
ciente disso que é uma necessidade
talvez hoje não hoje não amanhã mas
daqui a algum tempo certamente a gente
vai ter que ter alguma capacidade de
adaptação porque o mundo está mudando
com velocidade muito rápida mas sete né
gente sempre pensou mundialmente esse é
um problema do brasileiro brasileiro não
pensa global brasileiro pensa local
isso vai um pouco da cultura nacional e
até um pouco da o tamanho do brasil no
mercado brasileiro é muito grande
é um brasil oitava maior economia do
mundo mas a gente tem que pensar que a
gente vive em israel é hoje uma das
maiores potências de inovação do planeta
israel é um bairro de são paulo e ele
tem muito mais empresas é como faturando
mais 1 bilhão é com valores maior de 1
bilhão de dólares o que o brasil porque
porque eles pensam globalmente estão
atingindo o mercado global de uma forma
muito mais eficiente do que o brasil de
novo israel é um ovo não sei se alguém
já fui lá mas é muito pequeno e eles
estão com uma política muito
interessante e inovação que é exatamente
a gente está tentando ajudar o brasil a
fazer aqui em alguns fóruns que a gente
participa mais importante agente
inovação inovação nada mais é do que
isso né
nossa reação saia da sua zona de
conforto saiam das suas está na palavra
não
muito que o que tentar adivinhar
inovação é isso se mexam sair da sua
zona de conforto inventar moda não vai
sentir não você faça empresário no
brasil como joão disse é mastigar vidro
não é simples sejam tem momentos muitos
momentos de vontade de desistir por uma
série de motivos
mas vale a pena a caminhada é a
caminhada vale mais do que o do que o
final a chegada então vale a pena e o
sucesso é logo ali na esquina é só a
gente ter trabalho foco e muito
conhecimento do investidor vem as
parcerias vêm se a gente tiver muito
coração muito amor quando a gente faz
muita no trabalho
agradeço aos incrédulos ness e imagino
quantas vezes chamado de doido por ter
entrado em luta você não tem noção é é
agir um executivo com o carro secretária
e tudo sai você ventura no startup que
até hoje é não tem um sistema comercial
é só sistemas de prototipagem teste
imaginam que é isso então não aceitem
isso usa isso com a favor de vocês como
vou te mostrar que realmente mostraram
escutem trabalhem e vamos lá
efetivamente quem mundo mundo são
aqueles que falam que vão mudar o mundo
né
não tem nada que é segredo quem é doido
o suficiente para pensar nisso é o que
realmente faz fazem né
ele está fazendo isso está tentando
fazer isso
a gente tem tido algum sucesso sair é
uma ideia já tem 12 sistemas vendidos no
planeta
então a gente tem conseguido entregar
algum benefício e ir pro pro mundo e
você vocês desafio vocês já pensaram que
acho que a provocação é que vocês vão
fazer sair daqui que vocês vão fazer
pelo mundo que vão fazer o seu bairro
que eles vão fazer pela sua família
vocês vão fazer pelo ser humano né gente
precisa de pessoas que efetivamente
pensem no ser humano de tentar uma
situação que realmente precisa trazer
benefícios e melhorias no nosso dia a
dia
a inovação vem de oportunidades e
necessidades
usem as duas coisas para desenvolver o
seu próprio negócio e tenho certeza que
vai dar certo
falei que mostrar um pouco do rapper
lupe sair
joana pela restauradora
e já vida baseado no show
o júri de fala de pesagem do força
o jec até água
a banda competição
já cheguei a volta de dezembro só de
praças cfap bom jogo a pele pois minha
avó tio já se esteja distante onde é o
prêmio de som vem aí quem é que é pronto
ele ajudou a proporcionar lídio sohn
cheguei me criou a dish
roma disse que ia ver de novo gueto
wimdu vergonha de estar com ela até eu
vos amo - antiga abic o melhor para
evitar essa marcha é que nem isso né
davi hora e pouco vocês entertainment
deixe jogou uma pedra no pé
o setor já não é mais a mesma cor de
sangue
7º a china irá ver com sua hispania
o seqüestro não desejar
teve aluno pedir
[Música]
ah
isso aí gente
e aí está ela vai conhecer o nome de
vocês muito obrigado
bom dia a todos grande abraço